Now watch here. Jay the th don't judge
Jay the th you can't judge. You need you
can't be judging. All right. What do you
do with this right here? John 7:24.
>> And I'm going to show you the context. M
John 7:24. Do not judge according to
appearance, but judge with righteous
judgment. He just told you you can
judge, but you must judge righteously.
And what's your righteous standard? The
Bible.
Oh, okay. Okay.
>> Okay. Now, the passage that they
misquote to you is this.
And in the faith formation, they didn't
teach you this either, huh?
>> No, they don't teach me anything.
>> Son of whiskers. Can you tell me who was
teaching that so I can get him fired and
take his job?
>> Oh. Oh, they don't work anymore at a
church. So, it's
>> I wonder why. Just kidding. Anyway,
Matthew 7:es 1-6. Watch here. This is
what they quote. Do not judge so you'll
not be judged. See, no, no, no. Finish
it. For with what judgment you judge,
you'll be judged. With what measure you
measure, it will be measured to you. And
why do you look at the speck that is in
your brother's eye, but do not notice
the log that is in your own eye. He's
talking about don't be a hypocrite
condemning someone for a sin when you
yourself are living in unrepentant sin.
You understand what he's saying?
>> Okay. Okay.
Because the log, okay,
>> but let's finish it.
Or how can you say to your brother, "Let
me take the speck out of your eye, and
behold, the log is in your eye." Did you
hear this part?
>> What did it say?
>> How can you?
>> Let me take a speck out of your Oh,
okay.
>> And behold, there's what in your eye?
the log.
>> In other words, don't be a hypocrite.
For example, let's say your brother gets
high and you go,
you need to repent. You're evil because
you're addicted to marijuana and all the
while you're committing fornication,
sleeping around with guys.
>> Okay,
>> that's being a hypocrite and judging
hypocritically. You hypocrite. Now,
watch. Let's finish it. First, take the
log out of your own eye. Then you will
see clearly to take the spec out of your
brother's eye. So he just said you can
judge when you yourself are not a
hypocrite.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> So why do you say do not judge?
>> I don't know. I was told that I just I
think my issue is I hang out with too
many Protestants and they end up
confusing me.
>> No, there are Catholics who say the
same. I've heard that. But now my point
is listen to me. Did Jesus say you can't
judge or don't be a hypocrite condemning
someone for a sin while you're guilty of
another sin and you know you're sinning
but you justify. For example, let's say
again your brother, we'll take him an
example. He's getting high and drunk.
You're a wicked hypocrite. You're a
sinner. Jesus ain't in you. You're doing
drugs. Repent. And you're sleeping
around committing fornication. And you
know it and you do it anyway. Are you
not a w vile hypocrite?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Oh, you have no business then to condemn
your brother?
>> Do you understand the context now?
>> Yes, I understand that now.
>> But now let's look at Matthew 7:6. You
want proof? Jesus says you can't judge.
Matthew 76.
>> Read it for me slowly, sister.
>> Okay. It says, "Do not give what is holy
to dogs, and do not throw away your
pearls before swine, lest they trample
them under their feet and turn and tear
you to pieces."
>> Now, who are these dogs and pigs he's
talking about? He's talking about real
animals.
>> No, sir.
>> He's talking about who?
If it's not animals, who's he talking
about?
Is he talking about us judging
other people like our sins?
>> He just said, "Do not give what is holy
to dogs." Who are the dogs? Is he
talking about animals?
>> No.
>> So, who are the dogs?
>> I don't
>> If they're not animals, what are they?
Aliens that visited Jimmy?
>> No, obviously they're humans, but
>> Oh, wait.
That means I have to judge that this
human is a filthy dog so I don't waste
time with him. That means Christ is
telling you judge and discern whether
that guy is a dog. That's a judgment
call.
>> Okay. Okay. I didn't see it like that.
But well,
>> think about it. He's saying you must
make a judgment call call and discern
whether this person is a dog and a pig
that will only mock and ridicule the
faith and blasphemy and slander the
Lord. So you stop giving him what is
holy. But that means I have to then make
a judgment. This guy's a dirt bag. This
guy's a dog. Hence why I call people
dogs, pigs, swine. When they come here
and mock and ridicule and insult, where
do you think I got it from?
So, isn't this a judgment that I'm
judging this person because he mocks,
slanders, ridicules, and so now I have
to cut ties with that person?
>> Yes.
>> But I thought Jesus says, "Don't judge."
>> I don't judge. But obviously, if there's
somebody that's still Oh, so there's
somebody that's still kind of they're
still like living in the world, then
>> Wait, hold on, sister. I don't know.
Maybe I'm slow or you're slow and you're
making me slow. Okay.
When I call you a dog and I don't waste
my time with you, am I making a judgment
call that you're a dog?
>> Yes.
>> But Jesus says that what that's what
you're supposed to do. You must realize
and determine this person is a dog. So
he's telling you, judge.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> You sure you got it?
>> Yes. Yes. Yeah. I mean it makes sense. I
mean that's why
>> speak a little louder in the mic. I
can't hear you.
>> Okay. That's what I'm saying. It makes
sense because you're saying it's it's a
righteous judgment. So we judge people
according to the Bible. So
>> not only according to Bible this
statement in itself if it's talking
about human beings, he's telling you
some humans are dogs and pigs.
He's telling you do make a judgment.
>> Yes. Yes. I I
>> for me to determine you're a dog, that
means I made a judgment call, right?
>> Yes.
>> She's a dog. That means I just judged
you. You're a dog and I'm not going to
waste my time. So, is Jesus allowing you
to judge people and determine whether
they're dogs or not?
>> Yes.
>> There you go.
So, where did you get that? Jesus says,
"Don't judge.
Um,
good question.
>> So, he's telling you,
look, some people are dogs and pigs.
Learn to discern who are dogs and pigs.
And don't waste time. Well, the only way
I can discern if you're a dog, if you're
a pig, is if I'm judging you because I'm
seeing your behavior.
Right.
>> That makes sense. Yep. That makes sense.
>> So, does the Lord tell me I have the
right to make that judgment?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Because he just said, "You
Christian, don't give what is holy to a
dog or give pearls to a pig." But Lord,
that means I'm going to have to now
judge and determine whether this person
a dog pig. Exactly.
Okay, that makes sense.
>> All right. And now let me show you where
the apostles did that they determined
this guy's a pig. This guy's scum. This
guy's a dog. You ready?
>> Mhm.
>> Now when I show you that, don't tell
anybody because they think that to be a
Christian, it just has to be nice and
just to be a feminine. Love you dy jada.
I just love you, sister. Okay? So please
don't share this with anyone. Right?
>> All right. I don't want anyone else to
know. It's just you and me. Even though
the world is watching. Shh.
>> Are you spitting at me, sister?
>> I'm laughing.
>> Cuz you kept going.
>> What does Paul say about his Jewish
opponents who are opposing him and
accusing preaching a false gospel? What
does he call them? Philippians 3:1 and2.
Can you read that for me?
>> Uh,
says it says, "Finally, my brothers,
rejoice in the Lord." a little louder so
we can pretend you're screaming at your
mother like you usually do. Good.
>> Finally, my brothers, rejoice in the
Lord. To write the same things again is
no trouble to me. And it is a safeguard
for you. Beware of the dogs. Beware of
the evil workers. Beware of the
mutilation.
>> He's talking about Jews who are telling
you got to get circumcised. What did he
call them?
>> Dogs, evil,
>> and mutilation.
>> So, he's doing what Jesus said. Make a
judgment call. If you see their dogs,
don't waste your time. Avoid them.
>> Oh, okay.
>> You sure you're getting it? Cuz you kill
me when you go, "Oh, like you didn't
get." You're getting it.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Second Peter 2:20-22, Peter talks
about people who started out as
Christians, but then left the church and
started their own heresy, a false
church. Okay?
>> Look what he says about them. Read
slowly and loudly. Read loud like you're
shouting at your mother like you did
today.
>> Okay. For if they are overcome having
both escaped the defilements of the
world by the knowledge of the Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ and having again
been entangled in them, then the last
state has become worse for them than the
first. For it would be better for them
not to have known the way of the
righteousness than having it known to
turn away from the holy commandment
handed onto them.
>> Now pause. What he's saying is these
people converted to the Christian faith.
They learned about Jesus. They learned
how to live holy lives and they were
living holy lives. Then they left
to start their own cult and preach false
teaching. And he says now their judgment
is worse
because they knew who Jesus is. They
heard the truth and they left it for a
lie and now deceiving people. That means
on the day of judgment, God will punish
them more severely. You know what that
means?
>> Yes.
>> It means the more you know, the more
you'll be accountable, right?
>> Yep.
>> Now, what does he say about them? What
are their characters like? Now, read 22.
>> The message of the true proverb has
happened to them. A dog returns to its
own vomit, and a cell after washing
returns to wallowing in the mire. Oh, so
you did what Jesus said. He determined
they're dogs and swine and pigs.
>> Sheesh. Okay.
>> That means this is a judgment call,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Because he made a judgment. Now look
what Revelation 22:15 says. Who will be
in hell outside the kingdom? Read it for
me.
Outside are the dogs and the sorcerers
and the sexually immoral persons and the
murderers and the idolatrous and
everyone who loves and practices lying.
>> Who will be outside?
>> The dogs and the sorcerers and the
sexual.
>> Who are these dogs that will be outside
the kingdom?
>> That would be the ones. No, that would
be the human beings who are not living
up to what Christ
>> got it. So John called them dogs.
>> Yes.
>> All right. There you go. So don't be
misled by people. So that answer your
question.
>> Yes, I did.
>> You good? You sure?
Yes.